[Music]  New York Washington DC  sokovia  [Music]  okay that's enough captain people are  afraid that's why I'm here  we need me put the check  whatever form that takes I'm game I'm  sorry Tony if I see a situation pointed  South can't ignore it sometimes I wish I  could sometimes I want to punch you in  your perfect teeth  I know we're not perfect  but the safest hands are still alone  I was wrong about you the whole world  was wrong about you  they're coming for you  and not the one that needs to watch  their back this doesn't have to end in a  fight Tony  but you just started a war  we're still friends right Spezza no  hardly  Tommy he's my friend so was it  all right I've run out of patience  underoos hey everyone  New York Washington DC